we start with a round of applause for a
Tony nominee we've got a Tony nominee in
the house whoa
this is a hell of a studio audience
Zachary Levi and Laura Benanti are
headed to the Tonys the co-stars are
each nominated for their performances
and she loves me on Broadway
congratulations on the Tony home I mean
I know it's not your first rodeo it's my
fifth rodeo
how's it feel five times though it feels
exciting this is my first nomination in
a Leading Actress category I've always
been in featured and I won four featured
Hey
bye so yeah it's exciting Lara is a
Broadway vet but this is only Zach's
second Broadway show ever
yeah a lot of like dancing whoopee
cushion right so what's it like to be a
first-time nominee for the former chuck
star yeah it's really it's really really
nutty to be in this kind of conversation
with these other incredibly talented
guys it's it's super weird with anything
like this you got a you receive it and
you're grateful for it and but you can't
you still got to kind of take it a
little bit with a grain of salt because
because Hamilton's not nominated
juggernaut is gonna sweep it off still
Hamilton does have some stiff
competition and she loves me which the
movie you've got mail is based on it's
up for eight Tony's including Best
revival of a musical I'm assuming you
bring your husband yeah whoo um he's
really excited to meet a certain person
am I gonna mean Bette Midler I don't
know
hey can I should get my hair done and
it's straight let me start my censuses
he likes to fornicate with women
particularly this one right but he loves
Bette Midler except the trigger if
you're watching like husband really
wants to meet you see yes Theatre Wing
get Bette to present the hashtag get
bets for them first I'll get that
happening say that's hard
you